ahead of today's senate floor debate on
the horrifying don't say gay bill shawn
mendes is the latest celebrity to share
his support for those trying to stop the
legislation sean quote tweeted equality
florida's original tweet which showed
students rallying on the steps of the
capitol and told his fans florida call
your senators hashtag let free florida
say gay on last weekend's saturday night
live openly queer star kate mckinnon
stopped by weekend update to share her
thoughts and
well mock the ridiculous bill i am
deeply
gay sorry
deeply concerned it just feels like this
is going to make kids
gay and trans sorry depressed and
suicidal
and i just i think these laws are
lesbians sorry unconscionable
if you can't say it you might as well
sing it
[Applause]
see it is so darn catchy gay gay gay gay
gay
even oscar nominee ariana debose
nominated for west side story at the
upcoming academy awards thought so too
she tweeted kate's original snl segment
while also singing the new anthem she
said cue me belting from the rafters
i love it so much
kristen johnston took to her twitter and
said say gay embrace who you are and
just know there are so many people who
love and accept you just as you are
hashtag say gay
kerry washington also took to her
twitter to share her outrage about the
bill tweeting
horrified by what is happening in
florida children deserve to be who they
want to be to be their true selves if
there was ever a time to register to
vote it is now
she's right about that billy eichner
also tweeted does everyone realize what
is happening in florida with this don't
say gay bill that to acknowledge the
existence of lgbtq plus and trans gnc
people in classrooms could get teachers
students sued please make yourself aware
if you aren't this is very dangerous
now even us president joe biden has
showed his support for the queer
community and spoken out against the
ridiculous bill tweeting i want every
member of the lgbtqi plus community
especially the kids who will be impacted
by this hateful bill to know that you
are loved and accepted just as you are
i have your back and my administration
will continue to fight for the
protections and safety you deserve
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos